how is it being new dads oh my goodness
it's the most amazing feeling in the
world i'm under a lot of pressure to
have my toenails and fingernails painted
oh
look at you y'all are nailing it how do
you think your daddy did great you did
great i'm
breed did you have your pet scan
[Music]
the louisiana man's been showing his
daughter love and encouragement by
slipping her daily inspirational lunch
notes like this
addison you're a diamond deer no one can
break you it all started when this dad
became suspicious that his daughter was
being bullied at school to date he's
written over 600 notes of positivity and
now he's helping other parents find
encouraging words to share with their
children so let's talk to this dad and
his 12 year old daughter what's up chris
what's up daddy
hi so chris when did you notice addie
was maybe having issues with bullying
yes so uh fourth grade it was her fourth
school in five years
and i just knew something feel right so
on the third day of school
um i slipped her a little note just to
tell her that
you can make a difference in anybody's
life and i put in her lunchbox and
that's where it began and a couple weeks
later we were running late uh one
morning and she said hey you're
forgetting my lunch note and that's when
i knew that she was actually reading
what i was writing chris your notes are
helping other parents as well right yes
so uh in 2018 her uh middle school
teacher and principal actually suggested
i put him in a book and it's called
lucky enough
and it's those first 160 notes or so
from fourth grade um unfortunately none
of your quotes or lyrics made it in that
year but uh this week there was a
special kelly clarkson message for sure
yes
i love it you've great taste
well jonathan give us the story behind
the lightning bolt haircut in that
picture so hunter was born with a
condition called craniosynostosis
and that is where the plates in the
skull fuse
sooner than they should or fused
prematurely
and it causes some abnormal growth so in
hunter situation it caused his skull to
grow
long or elongated and it wasn't growing
wide so we went to
the doctor to have it checked out
and they told us the news that we
weren't wanting to hear that he would
have to have um an invasive
reconstructive skull surgery and so he'd
had that when he was two years old he's
five years old now
and so the story behind the haircut
um was he asked me he's like do you
think that my lightning bolts are cool
and i was like dude absolutely i wish i
had some lightning bolts and he was like
well then why don't you go get some why
don't you have them if they're so cool
and so that's exactly what i did we went
to the barber shop
and i asked him to match the the
lightning bolt pattern um in the exact
formation of his scars well i'm telling
you what man i don't know if you're into
superheroes like iron man
and all those guys but i'm i think that
you look like a superhero with it it
looks like a really cool thing that
people go and get their hair done and i
and thank you so much guys because y'all
sharing that moment it really does help
people kind of embrace what might be
different about them but makes them
stand out in a really cool way so
michael how did you get started making
clothes frayva uh so i've always been
creative since i was a kid
my creativity i always say saved my life
it's um how i kind of cope with feelings
of not having my father raise me
so when i became a dad i was trying to
figure out how i could actually bond
with ava um so my sister was sewing and
i just decided that i wanted to try it
too
um went to the thrift store um
purchased some women's clothing upcycled
it for ava and just put it on her she
started naturally posing and modeling
and here we are now seven years later
still doing it together
so ava how do you feel about the clothes
your dad makes you um i feel um
wonderful and close to my dad makes for
me um i feel confident i feel amazing
and i feel like i'm in a whole new world
um my favorite dresses that my dad has
made for me is from the daddy daughter
dance
and he has inspired me to start selling
myself i have a cool pink sewing machine
um and my dream is to go to fit and
create my
a fashion
design um but michael i understand other
dads have been reaching out to you as
well right yeah so when i started this
journey my one of my purposes was to
actually encourage other fathers to
find and engage and be very present with
their kids especially their daughters um
so through this experience i've had dads
reach out wanting to learn how i started
um i'm always proud to kind of share my
fatherhood experience and especially
proud to be a girl dad
well that's what happened to
six-year-old ella this year on her
birthday she walked through the wardrobe
and came upon a recreation of harry
potter's diagon alley
there's an owl shop a quidditch supply
store and so much more it's incredible
this was the inspired work of her dad a
single father who spent months putting
it together we have him dialing in from
london hi dylan how you doing
[Applause]
so let's go in and check out your diagon
alley i'm still i'm a harry potter nerd
man so this is so cool
cool right okay we'll take you through
right you ready ella we'll take everyone
through here
here we go
this is the coolest thing ever
what cheers
there you go guys have you got something
in there to give to kelly
oh dude shall i go
i'll get it here we go i love you so
kelly yeah
[Laughter]
it's teamwork so she's made you a little
a little bag um with some of her
favorite things from her favorite shops
which she wants to send she wants me to
send it to you by al so i'll do my best
oh my gosh thank you so much dylan and
ella i'm liking your post right now
okay so we all know breakup suck but 22
year old kinsey from san francisco has
discovered the perfect cure all thanks
to her dad just check out this tick tock
post
[Music]
your dad seems amazing
is this like a tradition that if you
ever have a breakup he takes you to
disneyland it's a beautiful thing
so basically i had this minnie mouse
doll when i was
little and my parents passed it down to
me from a daughter they had before me
who died when she was a baby and so i
was never able to meet my sister and i
felt that this minnie mouse was the only
connection i was going to ever have to
her so i just became obsessed with
minnie mouse and all things disneyland
so disneyland is just like a really
really special place for me and my whole
family because of that and so come my
first breakup in high school my dad was
like
i need to cheer her up and so he took me
to the happiest place on earth and it
worked like a charm
come my second big breakup in college he
knew exactly what to do this time as he
learned and he took me to disneyland
again this time my mom came along as
well and we all just experienced the
magic together
oh that's so sweet i love your family
and that's a beautiful full circle
moment with the minnie mouse thing and
tying him with disneyland that's a
beautiful thing that your family will
have forever thank you so much for
sharing with us
[Music]